Hey, this is Jake with The Verge...
...and we're gonna take a look at Magic Instruments' rhythm guitar.
The company is basically trying to reinvent the guitar...
...by removing all of the strings along the fretboard...
...and replacing them with different buttons.
And by pressing one of these buttons, you program the guitar...
...to play a specific chord and then you just strum and play.
The idea is that it's a lot easier to learn to just press different buttons...
...than it is to figure out the specific fingerings...
...of every individual chord you might wanna play.
And it's definitely true.
It is a lot easier to just pick this up and start strumming...
...than it is in an acoustic guitar.
But there's still some learning to do.
You have to figure out which button to press to make which sound...
...and you have to learn how to move your fingers along the fretboard,...
...which is a lot like an acoustic guitar.
To help you learn, Magic Instruments is launching an app...
...that's basically like Guitar Hero.
It'll lead you through popular songs button by button,...
...telling you what to press to make which sound.
The hope is that eventually you'll get pretty comfortable with it...
...and be able to go off and start playing songs on your own.